when you made the transition you said it
you're ten you that's when you started
being yourself more on stage that's when
I changed my style myself was I yeah I
just changed what I was gonna be talking
about I don't want to talk about nothing
that somebody Jimmy what I was gonna do
a lot more research lot more studying
going depth on she didn't find the most
gruesome [__] to me funny there's an
even even stuff that one side me out you
ain't you ain't you haven't been telling
these stories people don't realize
people realizes at all I hadn't told a
prison story until I did this is not
happening
whoa and you've had multiple albums
before that that isn't that's Wow I had
got I hadn't told not one prison story
what was like consciously or you just
said that was very conscious I don't
want people to think I was someone trick
oh all he doing everything all right I'm
not the prison coming so it took me 16
years I was gonna standing for 16 years
before I ever remember I did it oh aight
i did Def Jam how the season finale of
Def Jam I was on camera view 2001 to
2004 I was on off the chain I was on
build better who got jokes I don't know
a lot of stuff before I did this is not
having and you had the vision to know I
don't want to be that so I'm saving that
not even thought I was gonna ever even
do it was just it's like I told stories
to my friends someone David like man one
of these days when you got to say that
on stage and I never he's like
bill told me he said bunch stuff and
then the the thing comes when person who
is your mentor says hey man you don't be
going to be really the funny how funny
you gonna be is determined on how honest
you don't be
I mean I swear that's what you're gonna
be different when you decide that you
have or whatever honesty and whatever
truth you want to say that's when you
gonna start being [__] hysterical and
I was deal here grinning just like when
when Sharonda would told me which
sometimes she [__] forget that she
told me this cuz she like [__] forget
that she even know me and some [__] but
all the times on the cruise I never
forget it and this is a great thing [__]
and like she don't [__] know me but I
said I say this story and they're in
[__] the Detailers that I can
say it because it's gonna be nothing but
straight detail she was coming out of a
spa on the cruise she had on this
[__] long flowy thing that was like
blue and green with a little splash or
anything but it was white based this
[__] flip big flip hat on and we
talking and she said I had dreads at the
time she said I'll leave you tell you
something you won't be successful in
coming you gotta remember these two
things every man gotta want to be you
and every [__] gotta wanna [__] you -
series
and I and I thought about what she said
and it's the truth
to be successful in stand-up every man
gotta want to be you it won't be funny
every woman gotta wanna [__] you
eighty-five percent in any comedy club
made up of women if you are not
attractive nope
and I'm talking about one thing that you
ask any woman this is the psychologist
she when you go deeper into him you ask
any woman name you'll top three things
you want your man to be I guarantee you
[__] funny come up make me laugh
I guarantee cuz funny and sexy that
transcends you past hot what your
physical she look like a shame that she
was right and so I cut my hair I i tail
it up Al's already dressing with
tailored suits and [__] but I'll tail it
up more I switch my style up a lot and I
black combined with the L and she'll sit
together there's other kinds of the
people out there as well but like Dick
Gregory and D is waiting Rob Stapleton
there's a lot of other people who who
gave me solid as advice so when I get
ready to write a book which would be
sewn here um awesome it'll be a book of
quotes think the story that I'm gonna
lay the story out of how I got the quote
like it's gonna be the quote then it's
gonna be the story behind the quote and
then I want to get the person who who
told me the quote to sign in the book
I breath